In Israel, dozens of Israeli tanks, military vehicles and troops...
...gather near the border with the Gaza Strip,...
...after a ceasefire announced by Hamas...
...to end another severe Gaza escalation failed to fully take hold.
In Syria, thousands of Syrians took to the streets of cities around the country...
...to protest US President Donald Trump's decision...
...to recognize Israeli sovereignty over the Golan Heights.
In Switzerland, the United Nations said that children made up one-third of the casualties...
...in the attack on Fulani herders in central Mali,...
...the deadliest such attack in recent times...
...in a region reeling from worsening ethnic and jihadist violence.
In Algeria, Army Chief General Ahmed Gaid Salah calls for President Abdelaziz Bouteflika...
...to be declared unfit to govern,...
...following weeks of mass protests calling on the ailing leader to step down.
Finally from Thailand, regional election observation group the Asian Network for Free Elections...
...is criticizing the initial results of Sunday's general election in Thailand as "deeply flawed."